author and columnist mark Stein is a
praying man and he joins us tonight to
assess oh we've just learned from Nancy
Pelosi Mark said I'm not I'm not quite
sure what to make of that that but with
that was a press conference today by the
way we should note for her yeah what do
you make of that well I think actually
in a sense she does believe in divine
intervention they were let down by Bob
Muller who was the nearest thing to
Jesus to walk on the face of this earth
for the Democrats until he actually
issued his report they've been let down
by judges and now they're putting their
faith in the big guy himself and when
she says she wants an intervention
basically she wants God to send Moses
back down with a brand new tablet on
which the 25th amendment of the US
Constitution is inscribed and that Moses
will then persuade everybody else that
it's time for Trump to be deposed from
office and it's and it's a strange world
because the ostentatious religiosity of
mrs. Pelosi is at odds with the sheer
insanity of what her party is proposing
you the party has actually changed a lot
Tucker in the last couple of election
cycles you know the way it used to be
people like John Kerry would would twist
themselves like a pretzel to explain how
personally passionately passionately
personally opposed to abortion they were
but that they would never let their
deeply held personal Catholic faith
interfere with their legislative agenda
there's no pretense of that now she
leads a party that's in favor of fourth
trimester abortion pregnant men ms-13 on
every corner a sanctuary nation with
lawyers for any six billion people
around the planet who want to come here
and and claim the right to live here and
I think she's doing this in a sense to
portray Trump as the crazy one where's
there where as it's their agenda that is
crazy
but why go
through the motions I mean it's an
aggressively secular party an
aggressively anti-christian party
obviously as you said it wasn't always
far from it there were a lot of sincere
Christians Jimmy Carter's a sincere
Christian among others absolutely
there's no anti-christian and there's no
let's not lie about it why even bother
to give us the God talk well I think the
God talk is interesting because as I say
so much of this stuff like the abolition
of the sexes and infanticide is so off
the charts that I think they actually
want to create a kind of new religion
for secularists and they need to
actually cloak this in faith interesting
I think that's I think you're exactly
right